all right guys
bang bang i've got nick here with me
super excited to do this we're gonna do
a quick overview of real estate and i
couldn't think of anyone better to bring
on so thank you so much for doing this
sir
thanks for having me paul appreciate it
let's get started just with your
background
uh kind of where'd you grow up and how
did you get into real estate investing
yeah i'm 31 years old grew up in
southern indiana went to was lucky
enough to go to cornell in ithaca new
york to run track and field
where i met a business partner and we
started a small business that did pick
up and delivery student storage
called storage squad and we grew that
from our
dorm rooms up you know to 12 cities
23 major colleges and a couple million a
year in sales
2015 we realized that the service
business wasn't necessarily where we
wanted to
spend our 40s and 50s because you know
the world's on fire people running
trucks into things
a lot of problems people are expecting
uber type service i learned a lot about
logistics and how to run a business
but um you know as you know when you're
at the top of the chain you get a lot of
the calls that are not necessarily the
fun ones
so in 2015 we had some money set aside
in 2016 we started construction
new development of a self-storage
facility in upstate new york
2.4 million dollar project and it was
uh it was great we learned a lot it was
stressful we went a little bit over
budget
we ended up buying out a neighboring
self-storage facility in 2019
when we got it stabilized we we did a
cash out refi and kind of
loaded up our war chest and now we're
kind of on a buying spree in the last
16 months we've bought eight more
properties and we have
seven more under contract so real soon
here we're gonna have about a 25 million
dollar portfolio of self storage
that's the two two minute overview yeah
no it's fantastic and obviously
um it sounds like you've gotten kind of
a crash course and all the good parts
and bad parts of building these types of
businesses
let's start maybe just with a high level
like what are the advantages of
investing in real estate and why does it
seem like every rich person
owns real estate yeah real estate is an
asset class that slowly appreciates over
time i mean
you two three percent a year adds up but
the the beautiful thing about it is that
you can amplify it with leverage
um not very many people trade stock or
bitcoin on margin
i don't recommend that but a real estate
asset you can touch it you can feel it
you can sign leases that are longer term
so it's more secure and therefore banks
are willing to loan
60 70 80 of the value so you know if
your assets appreciating at five percent
a year but you only put in 25 percent of
the money
your 25 is really appreciating at 20
a year right because you're getting
appreciation even on that part
that the bank bought so over time if you
can operate real estate and you can find
a way to make money on it
it's a beautiful thing because
commercial real estate that's what i'm
in
it's a little different in the single
family rental where they kind of look at
what the guy down the street
bought a house for with the similar
dimensions but in commercial real estate
it's valued based on how much money it
makes
which is something great for somebody
who loves operating business and finding
a way
to make a piece of real estate make more
money and then when it gets more
valuable
that's when the magic starts to happen
with real estate you can really compound
and grow
absolutely and then uh when you think of
kind of the lay of the land in real
estate i think most people just think of
commercial and residential
is that an accurate kind of framework or
are there other components
you would add in there yeah so the money
is made in niche
real estate and when i say that i mean
all these other
small asset classes that people can get
involved in
that you wouldn't even think of i have a
i have a list here you know when you
think about short-term rentals that's a
that's a niche within single-family
homes but you got
executive rentals tiny homes
multi-family mobile homes
section 8 housing rv parks cemeteries
medical office
office hospitals professional office
dental offices large scale retail small
scale retail niche
retail i mean you got data centers sell
cell towers hotels hostels gas stations
factories
amusement parks vet clinics pet
crematoriums
wind farms you know solar farms all
these different things
where if you specialize in some of those
things instead of competing against the
bigger pockets crowd of everybody
who has 20 grand in their pocket wants
to go buy a single family rental or
duplex
you know if you're a guy who who can buy
marinas
you know in a town and operate a marina
you can make really good money if you're
a person who
can can buy and manage golf courses the
right way solar farms wind farms and
just for me
i happen to get into self storage which
i like i love it as a business model we
can i'm sure we're going to talk more
about that but
basically yeah there's there's hundreds
of ways that you can go with commercial
real estate and it's all valued based on
how much money it makes
why do you like self storage like why is
that your focus i like self storage
because
um it is recurring revenue and if you
buy a one million dollar property
you're going to have 100 plus tenants in
it
there's no other business where you can
have an average tenant paying 80
a month and have a property that's worth
more than a million dollars so what what
you have is
your your risk is hedged you know if you
if you buy a shopping center and it's
got a kmart
and a best buy in it and it's worth 5 or
10 million bucks but best buy
announces that they're going to go
bankrupt and stop paying your rent your
property is instantly worth half as much
on
in a day as soon as that news breaks
whereas in self storage you know if a
couple tenants move out and a couple
tenants move in
it's just the normal uh business cycle
so you're kind of your risk is kind of
hedged that's why i love it
got it and so when you think through
kind of um
the way that self-storage businesses
work you basically go in
you buy the property and then what do
you do to it to kind of
improve the actual um financials and the
overall value of the property yes
there's two types of self storage one is
these big multi-story
facilities that you see popping up all
over the place in major cities
that's class a storage there's
multi-storeys it's climate control it's
a little bit more complicated
i buy i found a little niche within a
niche right self storage is a niche i
found a little bitty part of that which
is
mom and pop self storage facilities in
smaller towns that we call road
facilities where there's you know just
doors facing outside and you can drive
up to every single storage unit
we found a niche where we can operate
these things remotely with software
so while a competitor down the street
i'll give you an example our first
facility in ithaca which i think we'll
talk about the deal
we have 51 000 square feet so it's a big
facility
but we operated on three grand a year in
payroll because somebody pulls up to our
facility
and there's a sign on the front of the
gate that says hey go to this website
you can rent a unit you can sign up for
a unit you can put in your credit card
and then when they do that stuff they
get an instant text message they get let
in the gate
they can go right to their unit there's
a lock waiting for them it's all
automated
and then when they move out they send us
a picture of their unit and
over 50 percent of the times they send
us a good enough picture that we can
re-rent that unit without even touching
it
so it's just an incredibly low touch
business whereas our competitor right
down the street in ithaca
is has a 50 000 square foot facility and
they spend 80 grand a year on payroll
to pay for retail hours for somebody to
sit in there answer phones
sweep floors and basically do a lot of
what our software does which is collect
the rent and rent the units
yeah and when you are thinking through
like
uh let's just call it kind of ground
maintenance for example
uh at what point is it hey it's worth
spending the money versus
maybe i shouldn't actually spend the
money and we can do something with
software
or you know tenants are only gonna go in
and out they really don't care if the
floors are swept or whatever
like how do you think through that uh
trade-off yeah we definitely keep the
place clean and safe i mean that's the
easy part once a week a custo
one of our employees drives by and makes
sure there's nothing there and we can
look at security cameras make sure that
nobody left a couch in a hallway and
things like that
but um yeah every every dollar we put
into these things we're thinking you
know
how and when is this going to pay us
back what do we have to do to make this
money back
so sometimes you want to operate a
business in a really affordable way
right and
and uh cut costs because net operating
income if you're not familiar with
commercial real estate net operating
income is what's left after
your revenue comes in and your expenses
go out what's left that's net operating
income
that's how much you're you know that's
how they value this stuff based on cap
rates and and multiples of that net
operating income
so if you can increase that everything
you can do um makes your facility way
more valuable so when we can cut out 80
grand in payroll
at a self-storage facility you know we
can create sometimes
500 000 or a million bucks worth of
value out of thin air
got it so let's just start with maybe
kind of a traditional real estate deal
we can pick a sector or we can just kind
of do
overall i want to walk through kind of
the financial engineering that happens
with real estate that
ends up being uh part of the advantage
right and so the first
is let's just hey we see a piece of
property we want to buy it
uh and the ultimate uh first goal is
we're going to do a cash
out refi walk me through the process
that an investor goes through
in terms of evaluating the deal
negotiating the deal closing it and then
getting us to that first cash out refi
yeah let's do it um let's talk sell
storage because that's my book right so
let's say we have a one million dollar
self storage facility that is for sale
and i look at it and i see some upside
i see the fact that they're paying a
manager i see the fact that they have
um sub market rents maybe they're
charging 70 for 10 by 10 when i know the
market rent is 100
for a 10 by 10 that's a deal that i'm
looking at right now for example and
let's say that the net operating income
on this facility is 80 grand meaning a
million dollar facility
you're making 80 grand a year in profit
now we might have to help each other out
with a calculator here but
um you know i come in and my goal is to
buy that thing
what i'm going to do is i'm going to put
a short term
adjustable rate mortgage on it so that i
don't have to pay a prepayment penalty
when i
when i refi out because i know there's
value here i'm going to create this
value and then i'm going to put new debt
on it so i go to my bank
and i get 75 percent of it bank financed
so i'm going to i'm going to find that
750 grand of it and i'm going to put in
250 grand of my own money on this one
million dollar facility
okay in revenue real quick let's just
pause there for a second so basically
what you're doing is
you're going to buy a million dollar
piece of property you're going to put
250k up of your own money you're going
to borrow 750 000
but the terms at which you're borrowing
that 750 000
are not as advantageous as you could get
but you're specifically optimizing for
flexibility because you
you have the plan to pay it back early
correct yeah there's something called a
prepayment penalty which can be
five or six percent of the loan amount
and if you if you pay
it in the second year which is what
we're going to do pond because we know
that this facility's got some upside
um six percent of 750 grand um
you know that can that can 50 grand is
not cheap to refi
that's going to suck up some of our
equity so what we're going to do yes
we're going to put flexible terms on it
whereas we might be able to secure a 3.5
interest rate we're going to secure our
five 4.25
because that little difference in
entrance interest is going to be five or
six grand over this time
but the real money's gonna be saved when
we refi so it does 80 grand a year which
if
i can briefly unders explain cap rates
here a cap rate is a percent return on
the overall spend
if you if you're buying at an eight cap
you're getting an eight percent return
on your overall spend and eight eight
percent of one million is 80 grand
so it's going to be valued at an eight
cap so let's just use the value of an
eight cap as a basis for how these
properties are valued right now it
changes right
a low risk property has a higher cap
rate because you need a higher return
i'm sorry a high risk property is a
higher cap rate a low risk property
let's say you
have a piece of property in downtown
austin that's going to be valued at a
five cap because it's you know less risk
more valuable for investors
so we're going to go in and we're going
to raise rents and we're going to cut
costs
that's what we're going to do that's
what i do best i go into a self storage
facility and i optimize that net
operating income
and let's say at 18 at the 18 month mark
our net operating income is now 120
thousand dollars
so 50 percent from 80 grand in profit we
went from 80 grand in profit to 120 000
in profit um that's not uncommon with
the people that we buy self-storage
facilities that have kept the rent the
same for five years and
and uh you know keep handwritten ledgers
handwritten paper ledgers every time
somebody pays rent
it's kind of crazy so i'm gonna take 120
000 i'm using my calculator and i'm
going to divide it by 0.08 to get my cap
rate now the building's worth 1.5
million
because it's valued based on how much
money it makes so i go back to my banker
and say hey mr banker we succeeded me
and pomp took this self-storage facility
now it's now it does 120 000 a year in
that operating income
it can support more debt and this is the
difference between
single-family rentals and commercial
real estate um
the bank looks at the value so we send
an appraiser in go to my banker he sends
an appraiser and the appraiser agrees
with me he looks at all my books and
says you're right nick this facility is
worth 1.5 million now
now the magic happens they loan the bank
can loan and they can put debt on assets
based on what it's worth right now
not what you paid for it so if it's
worth 1.5 million
we can put 75 percent debt on that
property we can get a 1.125 million
dollar loan
and still cash flow and we still own
that thing we didn't have to sell it or
anything
so what we do is we we have a now a new
1.1 million dollar loan
and we have old old loan remember of 750
000 so 1.2 1.125 minus 750 000
is 375 000 left over after we paid off
our original debt
so literally on the day you do this
what's called a cash out refinance
you get 375 000 put in your checking
account remember how much money we put
in the deal though how much money did we
put in this deal
250 so we just created 150 grand
out of thin air we still own asset that
is appreciating and cash flowing
and operating and giving us money every
single month and we have
150 grand left to go buy more storage
375 now we've taken out all of our
original investment and the beautiful
thing about this is that it's tax-free
it's not real income we haven't realized
a taxable event
yet okay so there's a couple of key
pieces here is you basically you bought
the property for a million dollars you
go and you make improvements now it's
worth 1.5 million right an outside third
party says yes it's worth 1.5 million
you go back to the bank say hey i want a
loan
you pay off the original loan all that i
think is straightforward
where people i think get lost is when
you pay off that loan
you still have the loan that you just
took out the new loan right and uh
you're still able to pay that through
the cash flows
and you still own the asset that asset
is not only one worth more money it's
actually cash flowing more money as well
right it can still be cash flowing 10 or
12 on the money you didn't spend anymore
you got that money back yep and so when
you take that money back right that
delta which ends up being i think in
this case you said 350
000 uh give or take the tax-free
component i think gets lost in all of
this
right you put 250 000 into a deal and 18
months later you're taking out 350 000
and you pay no tax on it explain why
that's tax-free
well it's got to be a certain you know a
certain type of debt qualified
non-recourse debt but
if you have a good attorney and you have
a good account you can do those things
this is it's not a taxable event you
haven't sold an asset so your basis
in the asset the uncle sam looks at the
basis how much money
did you have in and if you sell what's
your new basis if you're in stocks
anything you understand that there's no
taxable event so this is
this is debt now and you can write off
the interest on this new debt
against your profits so the snowball i
mean you can see if you conceptualize
this doing three four or five deals like
this a year over 10 or 20 years
the snowball can become absolutely
massive because now you got 375
000 you can go buy a bigger property and
if you're good at what you do
you know we do need to talk about the
risks here we can't get everybody all
fired up about levering up with debt
and not understanding that this is how
people lost everything in 2009 2010 when
the values
because real estate's not liquid you
can't just sell it so when the values go
up and the values go down
you have to be able to ride out the
storm and pay your debt service because
the facility
is valued at natecap right now but if
interest rates go up it's going to be
valued at a 10 cap which can drop my
value
and before long you're under water
because you only own that top 25
that the bank doesn't own so if it drops
25 in value
your equity is gone and you own you own
nothing the bank can take the property
that's what happened to a ton of real
estate investors
who got a bunch of debt on their on
their assets in 2009
you know when when that happened and how
do you think about the right
debt levels right because there's some
people who say hey i only buy things in
cash and obviously that's very hard for
many people to do
there's other people who say hey you
know the beauty of real estate is i'm
gonna go and i'm gonna put
five percent down ten percent down and
really lever all the way up how do you
just think about like what's the healthy
um you know debt levels to start with
and then do you aggressively try to pay
that debt down or do you kind of just
stick with
what i would consider a more traditional
kind of you know
pay it off as you go based on the plan
type approach
yeah that's a great question and there's
really two types of real estate
investors
there's people who go after cash flow
and there's people who go after
appreciation
if you're buying you know think about
the housing market
in austin texas um or in new york city
before cove
for the 10 years leading up these houses
were appreciating at 10 a year and
getting more and more and more valuable
the investors who bought there
realized most of their gains their
appreciation
that that is a risky kind of speculative
way to do business because
because if if the cycles change and all
of a sudden the housing market's not
going up anymore you can be caught under
water really really quick
but if you focus on cash flow and you
have a diversified tenant base and
you're confident that they're going to
keep paying you rent
that the factory in the self storage
town is not going to shut down and
everybody leave the town
you know there's risk in all this stuff
but i kind of think if you
cover your debt in a certain way and if
we weren't really in the weeds we'd talk
about debt constants and debt yields and
debt service coverage ratios and a lot
of
stress tests where you can kind of see
how much of a change can you really
absorb if things start to go poorly
but if you focus on cash flow and you
focus on yield instead of oh i really
want to buy this up and coming
neighborhood in austin because
i know that it's going to get more
valuable five years from now but yeah
what's your cash flow in that uh 300
a month okay so what if the guy doesn't
pay your rent for six months what are
you going to do then
you know gets risky got it and so when
you think about
um kind of the advantages of real estate
right one of this is this cash out refi
which basically allows you to very
quickly
take uh a relatively small investment
like 25
of a property uh and make improvements
you got to do work right there's risk
to it uh but you can get basically back
the
principal amount plus some profit uh
it's done in an
um uh non-taxable way and then you can
use that capital to pretty much go do
whatever you want right you can go
buy dinner for yourself you can go on a
family vacation or you go buy more real
estate
the other advantage is all around uh
depreciation
and kind of tax advantages let's talk
about that a little bit like
i think people hear like real estate
investors pay no tax right and it's kind
of this over generalization
uh there's truth in every generalization
and so kind of how do you think
definitely truth in that there's truth
in that i mean the the
i mean we don't have to get political
but the the united states government has
encouraged certain activities they
realized a long time ago that hey if we
make
this certain thing really tax efficient
more investors are going to do that
and it's been a blessing for our economy
because we have giant skyscrapers in new
york city that
kind of you know were encouraged by the
government to do things like that and
building
building real estate assets in our
physical world is really critical we
need hospitals to go to we need
grocery stores we need houses and so on
so basically what they've done is
they've
allowed this depreciation to take to you
know when you let's think about it two
different ways if you're running a
service business and you need to pay an
employee that's an expense
but you pay them right then that's an
expense when you're buying a piece of
real estate you're buying a one million
dollar self storage facility
but it's not really an expense that year
it's got a lifetime so you'd appreciate
it over time
is the way that you can write this off
as an expense against your taxes and
usually it's 39 and a half years for
commercial real estate
so you get to slowly write off that one
million dollar expense over
39 years and it decreases your taxable
income and makes your cash flow
look a lot better because you know it
might be only two percent of the value
but remember it's two percent of 100 and
the bank paid for 75
so you also get to write off part of
what the bank bought which is pretty
awesome
and then there's this thing called bonus
depreciation and this is where it gets
crazy
this is where you can say oh with that
self-storage facility it's also got
landscaping and that landscaping's only
got a seven year life span
and it's got this roof on it that's only
a 15-year roof
and it's got these uh this security
system that that's not worth 39 and a
half years so we're going to depreciate
all these individual things
faster and that's called a cost
segregation study somebody goes in and
they say
they split out your entire building at a
different depreciation
we're going in the weeds here different
depreciation life cycles so that you can
write it off against your taxes over
different times
well when they're really wanting to get
aggressive and they really want to
promote real estate
they put this bonus depreciation into
the tax code which allows you to in the
first year right now it's 100
bonus depreciation it changes okay trump
did that in 2017 before that it was
you know gonna die off and go slowly go
away now it's extended to 2023 it all
depends on the political environment of
how much they're going to motivate this
stuff
but anything that's under a 15-year
lifespan right now and don't quote me on
this i'm not an accountant
you can write it off in the first year
that you put this building in service
and a self-storage facility a hotel
anything of these things that you kind
of buy
even a rental property people who own
rental properties don't know that they
should get a cost segregation study done
and depreciate this stuff against their
assets
25 of the value can be written off on
year one sometimes of an overall
purchase price
you can't right you can't appreciate the
land at all you know the bill the core
structure of the building can't be
appreciated but the windows the doors
the hinges the landscaping the
improvements all that stuff
sometimes can be lumped into this bonus
depreciation so you and i pump when we
buy that one million dollar facility we
might get 250
000 of bonus depreciation as a tax
write-off in year one
the very first year so nick maybe help
us understand in terms of uh the bonus
depreciation what's the difference
between
uh going through the exercise of the
segregation study and leveraging that
bonus depreciation
versus what i'll call traditional
depreciation that an investor
would do without the segregation study
it's massive
yeah so it's you know a little over two
percent of the overall purchase price
per year if you do it on a straight line
39.5 year depreciation schedule
if you do a bonus you know cost
segregation study and get it done you
can get
25 of your overall purchase price
allocated to these quicker
life cycle timelines and um
you know it goes from 25 000 right off
to 250 000
write-off and if we do some math here on
that original example we had
you know our net operating income is 80
grand but out of that comes interest
expense so our cash flows
you know our taxable our taxable part of
it is going to be around
you know 50 grand or 40 grand and when
you're only making 40 grand a year in
profit on that
you know 250 000 investment on that one
million dollar property and you get a
200 000
first year write-off you know not only
does it
wipe away your tax liability on this
asset it can wipe away your tax
liability on
on a lot of other real estate assets so
basically what people do
who start making a lot of money from
older projects is they'll just put one
or two new
storage facilities in service every year
so if you and i go out and buy a million
dollar sales storage facility every
single year
we're going to get 200 000 in bonus
depreciation every time we do that
so if we buy two next year and two of
the year after that two year after that
we get
400 500 grand of tax write-offs every
single year
and before you know it you're building a
giant snowball of wealth
and paying absolutely no taxes yeah and
basically
when you do that um kind of adding to
the portfolio every year you're
basically taking the depreciation
and you're leveraging it for income from
the earlier properties right and that's
how you're basically shielding all of
the income
uh from paying tax exactly right and i'm
not a i'm not a
tax attorney and i'm not a cpa i got to
say that so people need to talk to
these people but if you have a cpa that
says oh you know you don't really want
to do a cost
segregation and you don't really want to
do accelerated depreciation because
you'll have recapture later when you
sell it
um you need to get a new accountant
i love it so when you think about this
um the average investor as they're
coming in looking at uh real estate
investing
it sounds like there's really kind of
three advantages right one is you get
the appreciation
uh two is you've got the potential for
um
the uh cash out refi and then three is
there's all these tax advantages that
you can
uh deploy how hard is this like do you
have a massive team
is it just you and and your partner like
walk through just the complexity
uh of the work that you're doing cause i
don't want it to sound like it's the
easiest thing in the world but also not
that it's you know complete rocket
science either
it's not rocket science but i'll say
it's hard finding an operational
advantage where you can increase net
operating income is very hard
you know there's a lot of people who
want to be in real estate it's a very
competitive game
self storage is a competitive industry
um it's not easy to find deals and it's
and you know you have to know how to
operate operating is the risk factor
everybody thinks that real estate is
passive
and you sit back and wait and collect
checks um
it's it's active and we are running a
business
inside of a business like we are
collecting rent from customers we are
calling customers we are marketing to
customers we are
presenting a product that customers want
to buy and it's a it's a
it's a huge risk factor but i will say
for an average self-storage facility if
somebody out there had you know was well
capitalized and wanted to go buy a 500
000
self storage facility um i have a video
on youtube that kind of breaks down a
473 000
one that we bought and we get three
calls a week from that thing popping our
software
collects all the rent and we don't we
don't stress
yeah and and so i guess that is a piece
of
if you're doing self storage and kind of
uh we're dealing with quote unquote
retail type
um you know customers how much customer
service infrastructure did you have to
build and kind of what are those calls
like are they
the more nightmare type stuff uh or is
it just simple stuff like hey you know
are you gonna be open certain hours
yeah if you're if you're a landlord and
you you have multi-family
uh you know housing complexes you're
gonna deal with some emergencies
if the heat's not on and there's people
in there that's a problem
you know if if the water isn't working
or there's a flood or the boilers out
you have a problem there's emergencies
you've got to be able to answer your
phone in the middle of the night
self storage is not really that way
right yeah people's got people have
their stuff there
the average customer comes to the
storage unit once every three months
um some of them rent for years and never
visit the storage facility
so we have what's you know in my opinion
is a is a low touch
sticky client and that's those are more
things that i love about self storage
where we don't have
hvac we don't have boilers we don't have
heat we don't have
appliances we have a steel box so it's a
little bit
less risk yeah and how do you think
about um
i'll call kind of technology competitors
right there was a point in time maybe
two or three years ago where
uh there's all these people who were
starting companies where i could press a
button on an app somebody would come to
my apartment or house they'd pick up my
stuff and they'd go put it in storage
themselves
is that something where sure you're
gonna have technology type
enablement in super urban areas but you
just pick the right location and you're
kind of insulated from that
or how do you view those types of
competitors yeah
it's it's clutter neighbor make space um
these companies that are really trying
out
a different model and and i do think
it's different i i i'm following it
i'm paying attention i'm gonna you know
i'm not gonna just sit back here and say
those are those guys are never gonna
have a chance but i'm buying i'm buying
self-storage facilities in
shippenville pennsylvania and erie
pennsylvania and elmira new york
and you know if i owned a massive
self-storage facility in manhattan i'd
be paying a lot closer attention to
clutter
and neighbor and make space than i am
but but as always there's early adapters
and there's people who want to pay extra
for that service to come and pick up
one one thing i really hate about that
business is that it's easy to get your
stuff
um all you gotta do is click a button to
get your stuff out of storage so i think
they're gonna have a lot of problems
with customer retention over the long
run
whereas for us if we were if we send you
know ten percent one of the powerful
things about what i do
is that we can we can send a 10 rent
increase a 10
rent increase and that goes straight to
net operating income so if we're
collecting 300 grand a month
or a year in rent on that one million
dollar facility i was telling you about
and we raise rent 10
that's 30 grand it goes right to net
operating income and it you know 10
percent of an 80
payment average tenant is only eight
bucks
whereas if i'm in a multi-family unit
where my average tenant's paying fifteen
hundred dollars
ten percent is 150 which is a lot
different for a family
um so you know it's a smaller piece of
the income pie so we can raise rents a
little bit faster but when clutter and
makespace raise rents
somebody might just click the button to
get their stuff back and then you gotta
pay to get it back to you whereas with
me they gotta rent a truck they gotta go
out there and they got to move it
what's your suggestion for how people
can get started is it go
find somebody who's doing this and kind
of learn alongside them
is it start with kind of your first
small deal
how do you suggest um the best way to
get educated
and kind of in the game yeah so i'm not
going to recommend getting into real
estate with no money
you hear that all the time you hear
people wholesaling um i got into real
estate and i'm in a position that i'm in
right now luckily because i started a
service business and if you know me with
the sweaty startup and
my big you know my podcast brand is is
you know start with service-based
entrepreneurship and make some darn
money first
everybody wants to go from zero to hero
in real estate but guess what pomp if we
didn't have that 250 grand
and honestly probably another 100 grand
sit in the checking account in case
things went bad
you and i are never buying that self
storage facility and when you got to go
raise money from a bunch of outside
partners and it's other people's money
the people with the money call the shots
and you can't own very much of it
so i'm gonna say how to start is go make
some money and if you're well
capitalized
and you know you have the operational
chops and you want to go buy a self
storage for sliding your town i think
it's a phenomenal way to build long-term
wealth i've been consulting people a
little package where i help them look at
a deal and go buy a self-storage
facility
that's been awesome for some folks who
want to do it but most of the time it's
you know go make some money doing
something else and forget about real
estate for a while
yeah and then when you think about uh
real estate investing
is this something where uh the people
that you know that are really successful
at this stuff
it's 90 their portfolio 20 of their
portfolio like how do you think of
portfolio construction
um and kind of the investing um you know
thesis if you will for people who are
focused on this full time yeah everybody
should have some real estate exposure
every
and when i say everybody i mean people
with net worth over a million if you
have a net worth over a million bucks
and you don't have real estate exposure
i'm going to suggest that you go on your
computer and buy public storage and
extra space storage
stocks right now because they're going
to pay a 3.5 dividend and they're going
to rise with inflation it's going to be
a very good hedge against your bitcoin
and your your tech stocks
um yeah i find i find people reach out
to me all the time and say look i'm
i'm i'm i'm cash i'm asset poor and cash
rich
and you know over time you really want
to have
real real estate as part of your
portfolio so i know folks you know me
i'm i'm 80
in real estate i do have our reserves
and equities but um i'm 80
of my net worth is in one asset class
because i'm doubling down and i'm very
confident what i can do
but if i was 55 and i was worth five
times as much money
i would try to have you know 20 in
storage 20 in multi-family
30 in industrial you know i i would i
would
hedge out my real estate portfolio and i
would also um
you know only make up real estate you
know 50 of my you know long-term
holdings probably
absolutely uh over the weekend you
decided to go on an absolute terror
and you sat down and started writing uh
and i saw you tweeting about it and i
was like what is he going to start
writing and next i know you're
you were tweeting updates and have like
25 000 words written
um and uh i think hundreds of pages what
are you writing and
kind of what's the thought process
behind uh behind putting this together
yeah if you know anything about me pomp
is that i'm a passionately curious kind
of guy
and i'm not afraid to put myself out
there and learn in public
and i've done it with my podcast i've
done it with i share all my storage
deals on twitter that's where i've kind
of
found an audience and where you found me
but yeah i get so many questions now
people who want to understand
just the basic dynamics of real estate
this cash out refi
the bonus depreciation and you know if
you look at
some of the other areas where just
people people have no idea
how it even works there's there's
private equity deal structures there's
investing with people who do what i do
and
and you know you can be a passive
investor and if you can write a hundred
thousand dollar check you can find
somebody who's going to go
do the operations and they're experts at
what they do and you can get passive
investment through that you know there's
huge mistakes that you can make in real
estate there's how it's valued and
there's all the terminology around it
and um i just started writing what would
be a letter to myself
at 20 years old when i had a little bit
of money but no real estate yet
because i've made some mistakes over the
years i got the wrong kind of debt on
buildings i've
i've you know had an environmental issue
pop up i've i've been unsure how to
raise money from private equity i've
i've done a structure where i didn't
make very much money
so i'm basically writing a pretty
in-depth you know
just a rundown of what you need to know
in real estate this is not a deep dive
on any one aspect but
i just started you know talking about
the stuff we're talking about right now
and
and i'm uh i'm a i'm a guy who
when i go in and i'm in the zone i i you
know blaze a trail and try to clean it
up later so i just started writing
how long is it right now i'm looking at
the document it's
25 000 words and 80 pages and i started
it uh
you know 30 hours in so it needs a lot
of editing
i love it uh in terms of where people
can go to find you where can we send
them to uh to find out when you actually
publish this thing
uh and also all of the uh the other work
that you're doing yeah this is a higher
level course it's not for somebody who
just wants to know a little bit about
you know real estate it's people with
the means with the money to kind of get
involved and kind of want to
figure it out but i'm going to release
this this little course but mostly i
give away almost everything i do for
free on my podcast which is called
sweaty startup and my website
sweatystartup.com but
it's twitter really i mean twitter i
think is a phenomenal asset if you make
it such if you follow smart people
you get a look into their mind day to
day and and when they're when they're
constrained to a character limit you
don't have to waste much time so i i
just love twitter
um and yes it's at sweaty startup on
twitter you can also email me
nick sweatystartup.com um if you want to
get in touch
awesome i asked the same two questions
of everyone before
i let them go and you'll get to ask me
one question to finish up the first is
what is the most important book you've
ever read
the most important book i've for my
business that impacted me the most was a
was a tax book
it read like a textbook it's called j
small business taxes by jk lasser that
thing saved me hundreds of thousands of
dollars over the years
but um a book that i don't think enough
people
you know give enough credit to is never
split the difference by
uh chris voss everything in life is a
negotiation
everything in life is about sales if you
can talk to people and you can really
understand their motives and you can and
you can find a way to click with what
matters to them
you can win in life and it's not just
business it's not just making money it's
it's literally
interacting with your friends to figure
out where you guys want to go out to eat
or
or building a healthy relationship with
your wife where everybody feels like
they're winning and it's
and it's happy um you know it's it's
chris really dives into the emotional
side of negotiation which i
you know i'm a logical guy but
negotiation is emotional it's not
logical you're not dealing with logical
being so the faster you can understand
that and the ins and outs of that
that's made me a lot better leader and a
lot better you know businessman
i love that second question is more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
oh yeah i'm a believer they got to be
out there somewhere i uh look at the
data right
what do you why are you a believer uh
yeah i definitely think they exist
somewhere i
i don't know if i'm as far as what is
the israeli like former space commander
or whatever now saying that he's been
talking to the aliens
and there's a glass i don't think
they're anywhere near as i don't think
they're anywhere near as close as we are
and i and i honestly think technology's
not nearly as far along as people think
it is i think we're gonna have a little
slow down with
ai and self-driving and all this stuff
and we're gonna have a 10-year clog here
trying to catch the checks that elon's
uh writing
i i love it what uh what question do you
have for me to finish up
um what's the if you could give one
piece of advice to uh to your 21 year
old self
and knowing your journey now i'm sure it
would be to not change anything but but
what's this one little thing that you
know i know you were a badass back then
but if you could just nudge yourself in
one little direction what would it be
go bigger and be patient i mean i i
think it's just a thing where uh
you know i think a lot about uh batting
average versus lugging percentage
and uh most entrepreneurs in general uh
they optimize for batting average they
don't want to fail
they kind of want to make sure that
every time they get up to bat they you
know they get a hit
uh i think that many of the people who i
respect
and many people that i know that have
been very successful in life they don't
worry about the batting average they
might worry much more about the slugging
percentage
um and this idea of when they get up to
bat they want to swing for home runs
um you know easy to say in hindsight but
uh you know that's probably the biggest
kind of mental shift that i've had uh
because i think that
if you understand you're gonna strike
out whether you're trying to get a hit
or trying to hit a home run
probably start trying to swing for home
runs and so uh i i think that that's
probably
it i love it man thanks for having me on
awesome listen everyone
uh nick has been uh a wealth of
knowledge on twitter highly highly
suggest go follow him
and i'll do this again in the future my
friend thanks for having me i appreciate
everything you do man we're playing in
the big leagues now
so i appreciate you having me on